[Music]
president XI jinping's grip on power
would now appear absolute if he has
enemies then they're hidden or unknown
or both
but some of those who've chronicled
she's career say you don't get to the
top of Chinese politics without
eliminating Rivals and making enemies
he does but it needs to be said that the
Congress is an act of State pageantry
the fact that this Congress is happening
means that these Rivals have already
been largely pushed to the sidelines
after becoming Communist Party Chief a
decade ago she vowed to root out
dishonest officials both high-ranking
tigers and low-level flies the campaign
went down well with the public
especially when it ensnared powerful and
Wealthy figures
Beau Chi Lai was a rising star of
Chinese politics even tipped as a future
president
but within months of she becoming leader
Beau was serving a life sentence for
corruption and abuse of power
no one was Untouchable including Xiao
Yong Kang the man who'd been in charge
of State security he's also serving a
life term for corruption and disclosure
of State secrets and The Purge is not
over and more than 4 million people
very effective
ly but also clamped down on his rivals
other analysts say the continuing
campaign against corruption ahead of
this Congress will ensure that she
strengthens his hand over appointments
to key decision-making bodies
she has led China for a decade now he's
expected to end precedent by being
appointed to a third term as party Chief
so having seized control of the Chinese
Communist Party Xi Jinping then sees
control of China and China has become a
lot less free a lot more oppressive far
less open than it was 10 years ago it's
an accumulation of power unseen since
Chairman Mao
[Music]
cult
strong
Al Jazeera